God, I want to do this political article. Okay, I've not read
all these messages. Apparently, they're like crazy and I'm gonna
look at them and I'm gonna go, "Oh, that looks like a couple
Discord chats I've been in before."
Now, I'm going to make it very clear on either side of this that
I'm just reading a title that says, "I love leaked messages exposed
young Republicans racist chat." That's the quote. Quote unquote,
I love says the racist Republicans. Okay, but that is a quote.
That's not me just saying that. Okay, thank you. Thousands of
private messages reveal young GOP leaders joking about gas chambers,
slavery, and >> everyone that votes no is going to the
gas chamber. When do we bring that side out? You're giving nationals
too much credit and expecting the to be honest. Are you going
to do whatever it takes? Great. I love is a quote. Also, we are
officially under consideration for a Trump endorsement. I'm ready
to watch people burn now. Stay in the closet. F slur. This girl
is fully
I mean that's not I don't even know what that is.
Oh, this girl girl is fully.
They didn't mention that one. Boom. They're dead. They love the
watermelon people.
Uh this one I could see this one being a little different than
people expect. All right. New York leaders of a young rep of
young Republican groups throughout the country worried that would
uh worried what would happen if their telegram chat ever got
leaked, but they kept typing anyway. They referred to black people
as monkeys and the watermelon people. Oh, but did they do that
or is this a Wick misunderstanding?
Is this like another Wick moment where Wick said watermelon people?
He meant the Palestinian people, not with a poop emoji on it.
Uh, I don't know. We'll see when we get to it. If it contextually
makes sense, if it's obvious, we'll just we'll just interpret
it in context when we get there. And mused about putting their
political opponents in gas chambers. They talked about their
enemies and driving them to and lot of Republicans who believed
who they believed support slavery. Okay, that's pretty yikesy.
William Hendricks, the Kansas Young Republicans vice chair, used
the words
soft and why' they have to do it exactly like the teacher ninja
and ninja
variations of a racial slur more than a dozen times in the chat.
Bobby Walker, the vice chair of the New York State Republicans
or Young Republicans at the time, referred to as epic.
Oh god. Peter Peter Jenta, who at the time of the was the chair
of the same organization, wrote in a message sent in June that
everyone that votes no is going to the gas chamber. Juna was
referring to an upcoming vote on whether he should become chair
of the Young Republican National Federation, the GOP's 15,000
member political organization for Republicans between 18 and
40 years old. I'm going to create some of the greatest psychological
tor physiological torture methods known to man. We only want
true believers, he continued. Two members of the chat
Okay, let's uh let's keep going. Everyone that votes no is going
to the gas chamber, and everyone that endorsed but then votes
for us is going to the to the gas chamber.
Okay. Uh when do we start bullying, dude? We have a solid three
people who can probably have them want to jump. We have a solid
three people who can probably have them want to jump. If they
vote for us, why would they be gassed? When do we bring that
side out? I'm going to create some of the greatest physiological
torture methods known to man, says. So, this is Genta PG.
We only want true believers.
Can we fix the showers? Gas chambers don't fit the
I'm ready to watch people burn now. We got to pretend that we
like them. Hey, come on in. Take a nice shower and relax. Boom.
They're dead.
Okay.
Uh, I don't know why you would ever do these in a chat that's
tied to something professional of yours. That's insane. Okay.
Like, oh man. Or or like tied tied to something. So, if it's
something professional where you speak this way professionally,
then maybe it's okay, but not for politics. You're trying to
have a a life in politics, right? Like having political power.
I'm telling you, this is always going to be used against you.
It was only a matter of time until one of these people had a
different like uh controversy and just leaked these things or
saved them to use against the other people in this group,
right? Like it's it's just low IQ to be participating in this
in any sense.
uh can we fix the showers? Gas chambers don't fit the Hitler
aesthetic. Joe Molino, who previously identified himself as the
general counsel for the New York State Young Republicans, wrote
back, I'm ready to watch people burn now. Annie K uh Katie Katie,
New York's national committee member said. The exchange is part
of a trove of Telegram chats obtained by Politico and spanning
more than seven months of messages among young Republican leaders
in New York, Kansas, Arizona, and Vermont. The chat offers an
unfiltered look at how a new generation of GOP activists talk
when they think no one is listening. J Talk just wants wignats
to be better at hiding with hiding the power level. Well, it's
just embarrassing if you don't know. Like, I'm sorry. It's just
low IQ behavior. That's what this is. This is all low IQ behavior.
That's all they're doing. What is this? Oh, you linked me a VOD
here. I I Okay, go find the time stamp as well if you want. Uh
if you want to look at that, but I'm I'm doing a different story
right now. 3 hours 20. Okay. Doing a different story. We'll come
back to it at some point in the near future. Okay. There's some
video of a dog trainer. We'll check it out. I'll keep it up here.
We'll know. All right. Thank you. Thank you, drama 101. We're
on to the racist group chat story now, though. So, thank you.
All right. Since Politico began making inquiries, one member
of the group chat is no longer employed at their job and another's
job offer was rescended. This is this is a gay thing to print.
Okay.
Since we started looking into these things and informing their
employers that they made these susp like very concerning comments,
I Okay, I guess that's weird for Politico to do, I guess, and
then report on as if it's ah that that just gives me a weird
vibe, this line.
Anyway, prominent New York Republicans, including Representative
Elise Stefonic and state Senate Minority Leader Rob Ortit, have
denounced the chat and festering resentments among young Republicans
have now turned into public recriminations, including allegations
of character assassination and extortion. A liberating atmosphere,
the 2900 pages of chats shared among a dozen Millennial and Gen
Z Republicans between early January and mid August chronicle
their campaign to seize control of the National Young Republican
organization on a hardline pro Trump platform. Many of the chat
members already work inside government or party politics, and
one serves as a state senator. Together, the messages reveal
a culture where racist a culture where racist, anti-semitic,
and violent rhetoric circulate free uh freely, I was going to
say frequently, and where the Trump era loosening of political
norms has made such talk feel less taboo among those positioning
themselves as the party's next leaders.
This will never be successful if you're this about it, ever.
Uh maybe, harmony. I don't think so, though. The more the political
atmosphere is open and liberating, like it has been with the
emergence of Trump and more right-wing GOP even before him, and
a more right-wing GOP even before him, it opens up young people
and older people to telling racist jokes, making racist commentaries
in private and public,
said Joe Figgan, a Texas&M sociology professor who has studied
racism for the last 60 years. He's also concerned the words would
be applied to public policy. It's chilling, of course, because
they will act on these views.
I mean, it's probably pushing them in a certain direction. I
don't think any of these people, okay, I don't think any of these
like 20-year-olds are actually looking to gas people, right?
It's bad. They should feel like some they should feel penalized
for this in some way, but like I don't think any of them are
really It's just like edgy edgy people using like edgy words.
I don't know. It doesn't seem to like I'd have to see some indication
that there's uh like actual behavior following this, right? I
think it's a part of a shift rightward. That is concerning, right?
For sure.
But I'm just saying that like this guy seems soy. That's what
I'm saying. The dynamic of easy racism and casual cruelty played
out in a often in often dark vivid fashion inside the chats where
campaign talk and party gossip blurred into streams of slurs
and violent fantasies.
And then you see the guys who are like saying the things. This
is Peter Juna. This is the guy who's going to gas people. Okay.
This is the guy who's gassing people. Um, I grabbed this. Somebody,
dude, hold on. You guys ever seen this? This reminds me of like
the Family Guy moment. Okay, I put this clip on Twitter. Hold
on. Just This guy right here is like the body shape. >> Tired
of not being able to find clothes that fit? I know I was. >> That's
why I started Stewie's Big and Tall Man Shop. If you're portly
or tall, you'll find a friendly atmosphere brimming with personalized
and expert
Hey Stewie, how's the weather up there? Very fair. Like our prices?
>> It's like it's exactly that. Now hold on. Just cuz they
they pulled up the one picture. So now I have to pull up the
rest of the pictures. Okay. It's not just this guy. A couple
of these people look fairly goofy. Okay. Uh there's this
There's this guy.
There's this guy. And there's this guy. Okay. I'm sorry.
This is I'll just I need to go find the clip because I've described
it before where Fuentes basically says, okay, it's like Fentes
he's talking about gropers at like uh at his speeches and stuff.
He's like, "If you look like this, if you're like fat, ugly,
horrifying in some way, I appreciate your support, but don't
be caught dead near me, okay? Do not be near me. Do not ruin
my optics. We're trying to look cool. We're trying to look hip.
We're trying to look hot and awesome. And do not come near me
if you're a fat loser, cuz I don't want to I don't want my picture
taken with you. I don't want my optics associated with you. Off.
That's like the whole Yeah, these are the these are the ones
he disowns. Yes. It's just very funny that
the Politico Politico is not respecting Quentis' wish for distance
from these people. Okay. Not respecting it at all. The group
members spoke freely about the pressure to cow to Trump to avoid
being called a rhino, the love of within their party's right-wing,
and the president's alleged work to suppress documents related
to wealthy financeier Jeffrey Epstein's crimes. child's crimes.
Trump's too busy burning the Epstein files. Alex Dwire, the chair
of the Kansas Young Republicans, wrote in one instance. Dwire
and KKD declined to comment. Molino and Hendricks did not return
requests for comment, but some involved in the chat did respond
publicly. Genta claimed the release of the chat is part of a
highly coordinated year-long character assassination led by Gavin
Wax and the New York City Young Republican Club. An illusion
to a once obscure inter intern
war that has now spilled into the open.
>> Cool.
Oh yes. Uh these logs were sourced by way of extortion and provided
to Politico by the very same people conspiring against me. He
said, "What's most disheartening is that despite my unwavering
support of President Trump since 2016,
rogue members of his administration, including Gavin Wex, have
participated in this conspiracy to ruin me publicly simply because
I challenged them privately." Wax, a staffer in Trump State Department,
formerly led the New York Young Republican Club, a separate city-based
group that is at odds with the state organization, the New York
State Young Republicans. He declined to comment. Despite his
illusions to infighting, Genta still apologized.
Oh, dude. How do you apologize for chats that are taken from
like seven months
How do you go like cuz for everybody else who has this thing,
they go, "Oh, these are comments I made in my youth, and I understand
they're like inappropriate." How do you go like, "Yeah, I made
that comment about gassing these people like 6 months ago. Yeah,
it was inappropriate. I've learned a lot since then." I've grown
as a person. It's pretty funny.
Okay. Uh, I am so sorry to those offended by the insensitive
and inexcusable language found within the more than 28,000 messages
of a private group chat that I created during my campaign to
lead the young Republicans. He said, "While I take complete responsibility,
I have no way of verifying their accuracy and I'm deeply concerned
that the message logs in question may have been deeply doed or
sorry, deceptively doed."
At least one person in the Telegram chat works in the Trump administration.
Michael Bartell's who according to his LinkedIn account serves
as a senior adviser in the office of general counsel within the
US Small Business Administration.
Bartell did not have much to say in the chat, but he didn't offer
any push back against the offensive rhetoric in it either. He
declined to comment. Oh, you can't, dude. You can't go after
this guy. This guy probably got invited was like, "Oh, this is
like a this is this is a total op. I'm uh I'm ignoring this.
Bye-bye. This is a total op. Bye-bye."
Right? I I feel like you can't you can't go after people who
didn't, you know, push back. It's like a bunch of people angling
to do some political thing. You push back, you start getting
like uh you start you start getting your messages leaked or with
you leaked, right? They didn't they don't even look young. It's
18 to 40. That's the age group for the young Republicans here.
18 to 40.
A a notorized affidavit signed by Bartell's and obtained by Politico
also sheds light on the interparty rivalry that led the restorer
restorer
war room telegram chat to be made public. Bartell's references
Wax as well. He wrote that he did not give Politico the chat
log and that Wax demanded in a phone call that he provide the
full chat log. When I attempted to resist that demand after providing
some of the requested information, Wax threatened my professional
standing and raised the possibility of potential legal action
related to an alleged breach of a non-disclosure agreement. Bartell's
claimed in the affidavit, "My position within the New York Young
Republican club was directly threatened."
"Wait, what? This guy's the snitch? This Bartell's guy?" So,
it says
he didn't push back. Was he just a Was he just a mole in this?
The hell?
Okay. Well, there is no excuse for the language and tone of Wait,
we
Walker.
Walker Bartell's, right? Walker Bartell's. That's the No. Who's
Walker? Who is this? This was uh Bobby Walker.
Dude, holy, this is a very long article. One second.
This is a very, very long article. Walker, Bobby Walker, who
now leads the New York State Young Republicans, touched on a
similar theme, saying that he believes portions of the chat may
have been altered, taken out of context, or otherwise manipulated,
and that the private exchanges were obtained and released in
a way clearly intended to inflict harm. He also apologized. "There's
no excuse for the language and tone and messages attributed to
me. The language is wrong and hurtful, and I sincerely apologize."
Walker said, "This has been a painful lesson about judgment and
trust, and I am committed to moving forward with greater care,
respect, and accountability in everything I say and do." 251
times. Uhoh. Uhoh. Slurs. 251 slurs
were used in this chat. No way.
Hold on. I need to turn this music up slightly. Like a little
too quiet right
I can't hear it well enough. Okay. Mixed into formal conversations
about whipping votes, social media strategy, and logistics. The
members of the chat slung around an array of slurs which Politico
is republishing to show how they spoke. Epithets like the fslur
and ninja appeared more than 251 times combined. In one instance,
Walker, who at the time was a staffer for talked about how a
mutual friend of some in the chat dated this very obese Indian
woman for a period of time.
Wait, is that a slur or, "Hey, professional acquaintances, I'm
mostly just networking with. That language you're using is not
cool. Like, be serious." Yeah, exactly. You just like mute the
thing and you don't engage. It's like, "Oh, these people are
not serious." You just like mute it.
Uh, dude, what? Magenta responded that the woman was not Indian.
She just didn't bathe often. Samuel Douglas, a a state senator
from Northern Okay, here's where it gets racist. She just didn't
bathe often. Some Samuel Douglas, a state senator from Northern
Vermont and head of the state's young Republicans, replied to
Genta. In a separate conversation, Genta shared that his flight
to Charleston, South Carolina, landed safely. Then he offered
some advice for his fellow young Republicans. If your pilot is
a she and she looks 10 shades darker than someone from Sicily,
just end it there. Scream the no no word. Gentto wrote, "Okay,
this pretty rough. Uh, it's going to be tough to come back from
that one." Okay. Although, if I were him, I would just go, "Hey,
listen. I'm just preaching the good word of Charlie Kirk." Okay,
you can't cancel me for preaching the good word of Charlie Kirk.
Charlie Kirk said the same thing. Charlie Kirk's on my page.
Charlie Kirk's on my team. Charlie Kirk thought the same thing.
All the Republicans let you off the hook, right? St. Kirk. St.
Kirk once espoused these same teachings. All right. Black woman
flying my plane. Get the out. Okay. Douglas did not respond to
request for comment. In a statement, Ort called for members of
the chat to resign. I was shocked and disgusted to learn about
the racist, anti-semitic, and misogynistic comments attributed
to members of the New York State Young Republicans. said, "This
behavior is indefensible and has no place in uh in our party
or anywhere in public life." This is Bobby Walker.
This is uh Bobby Walker is the person who now leads this group.
Right. Walker had been in line to manage Republican Peter Oberacer's
campaign for state uh Congress in upstate New York, but a spokesman
for the campaign said Walker won't be brought on in light of
the comments in the chat. O
yikes yikes. Okay, so actually maybe um
I wonder if Politico has much to do with it actually now that
I'm thinking about it. I thought that line from above was a little
weird, but now the line about the people not being there. I'm
guessing they probably were like, "Oh, what are these people
doing for work?" And we're going to reach out to those people
for comment. Yeah, I think that's probably a part of being like
journalistically responsible is reaching out to whoever they
work for, right? That's probably something you're going to do.
I don't think that's something you could really be judged for.
And if if you reach out to them, give them a heads up on the
story, it's probably just how that shit's going to go down. I'
I'd recommend not having a campaign slogan of we'll gas anybody
who doesn't vote for us, okay, in private. I think that's probably
not the best choice. You're trying to be a serious political
advocate. The private rhetoric isn't happening in a vacuum. Seeking
Trump's endorsement. The private ah I was going to say this.
The private rhetoric isn't happening in a vacuum. It comes amid
a widespread coarsening of the broader political discourse and
as incendiary and racially offensive tropes from the right become
increasingly common in public debate. Like from the literal White
House official accounts where they paint illegal immigrants with
different Pokémon cards and types and and write lore for them.
Like could could it possibly be driven by some of these things?
Last month, Trump posted an artificial intelligence generated
video that showed House Minority Leader Hakeem Jeffre in a sombrero
beside Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer, whose fabricated
remarks were about trading free healthcare for immigrant votes,
a false, long-running GOP trope. The sombrero meme has been widely
used to mock Democrats as the government shutdown wears on. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. In his 2024 campaign, Trump spread false reports
of Haitian migrants eating pets. and at one of his rallies welcomed
comedian Tony Hitchcliffe, who he who called Puerto Rico a floating
island of garbage and joked about black people carving watermelons
on Halloween.
Liz Houston, a white person spokesperson, rejected the idea that
Trump's rhetoric had anything to do with the chat membmber's
language. I mean, it does a little bit. It's the whole world
is becoming less politically correct. I I don't It absolutely
does a little bit. Only an activist left-wing reporter would
desperately try to tie President Trump into a story about a random
group chat he has no affiliation with, while failing to mention
the dangerous smears coming from Democrat politicians who have
fantasized about murdering their opponent and called Republicans
and fascists. Dude, it's the what aboutism from these people
every time. Every single person in this administration is like
so on point with the what aboutism, it's crazy.
No one has been subjected to more vicious rhetoric and violence
than President Trump and his supporters. How dare you publish
They're calling us fascists
due to them saying they're going to gas all of their political
opposition. The Young Republicans apparently members of the Young
Republicans from four different states
in the Restori
Restori
I'm just going to keep saying it weird restoer
war room chat. Juna tells his fellow Republicans that he spoke
with the White House about an endorsement from Trump for his
bid to become chairman of the National Federation. Trump of the
Republican National Committee ultimately decided to stay neutral
in the race. A White House official said it has no affiliation
with restore. Restore Y. Oh, restore young Republicans. Oh,
restore young Republicans.
Whoops. I thought it was uh I thought it was a different thing.
Jesus. Restore with restore young Republicans and that hundreds
of groups asked the White House for its endorsement. Gentto was
the most prominent voice in the chat spreading racist messages,
often encouraged or liked by other members. When Luke Mossman,
the chair of the Arizona Young Republicans, asked if the New
Yorkers in the chat were watching an NBA playoff game, Gent responded,
"I'd go to the zoo if I wanted to watch monkey uh watch monkey
play ball." Gentto elsewhere refers to black people as the watermelon
people. Okay, this guy just sounds like overtly racist. Like
very low IQ overtly racist. By the way, I say that not to say
that there's nothing morally wrong with his language. There is,
but like even people who were racist, like even if you were racist,
which I know there are a couple people here, you would you would
find this behavior despicable, right? Because it's like it's
it makes you look like a joke. I personally find it like morally
objectionable as well, but like it's it's just the lowest IQ
form of racism that you can engage in. There's nothing helpful
being done here, right? Like there's nothing you're not like
making a statement. You're not like >> I feel like a lot
of people who engage in some forms of racism might do it as a
way of like not really believing that race is a problem, right?
But there's no excuse for this kind of like uh like these kinds
of weird.
This is weird. Be honest. Imagine thinking there's high IQ racist.
Well, there's the kind of high IQ No, no, no. There's the like
Don't make me make me go pull the the Fentes clip. Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. Is this the quote right here? Oh, let me see
if I can find the clip here.
Why are you not Dude, don't do it without the quotes. Oh, I can't
find it. Whatever. Quent's quote about uh unironic racial hatred
being low IQ. It's It's just like having actual You could You
could like meme about racism, right? And maybe not be like a
person who actually hates other people based on their their characteristics.
You can make racist jokes, right?
You can do this. This is a thing that exists. But having like
um
>> having like just total disgust for people or total disdain
for people based only on their race is is pretty stupid. Like
only stupid people do that.
>> Uh no, Dingolingus, it's about judging people before
you ever meet them. Like having actual hatred for them before
you ever see them do anything or meet them. Obviously, Dingolingus
is um I I can't tell. A low IQ, not racist. Maybe the racism
is is undetermined at this time. Okay. The low IQ very determined
for him. Unlucky buddy. Hendrickx made a similar remark in July
about the monkey.
Um Hendrickx made a similar remark in July. Bro is at a chicken
restaurant ordering his food. Would he like some watermelon and
Kool-Aid with that? Jesus.
Hendrickx. It's also just like loweffort, like lowhanging fruit.
Uh Hendrickx was a communications assistant for Kansas's Republican
Attorney General Kris Kobach until Thursday. He also said in
the chat that despite political differences, he's drawn to Missou's
Young Republican organization because Mur Missouri doesn't like
fslers.
This is William Hendris. Damn.
Damn. I I feel like we could we can discern a different reason
for why these people might not like basketball. Okay,
we can we can discern a different reason. All right, dude. Also,
Politico knows exactly what they're doing, don't they? William
Hendricks during a portrait in Topeka, Kansas, July 20. Like,
hey, we're just throwing this in here for reference. Okay, we're
just throwing this this picture of him looking so so offensive
to the eyes. Just just like randomly. Okay, just randomly. It's
just for journalistic interest. All right, it's just in the public
interest. He's literally Wait, hold on. Does this actually work
in his favor? Hold on.
Hold on. This You're not wrong. Wait one second. You're not wrong
that he's literally built like a groper. Hold on. Hold on. Very
important.
Wait, is he trying to do this intentionally?
Is this an intentional thing?
Can we get We need to get this photoshopped. Okay, get the alleyway.
Put the Put this guy walking down the alleyway. Holy What the
[__] dude? This guy really believes in the cause
to go and set this go and set this portrait up. Uh, hold on
here. Top Ron, I'll send it to you. Just give me a second.
Okay, hold on. There's this. And then there's uh there's this
one as well, but I think this is like not I got like a low resolution
version. Hold on. Maybe this is going to be good though. No,
this is a better resolution version. Okay, there you go. All
right. All
>> Okay. Politico reached out to Denitri
>> I don't even know how to say this. uh Denadri Herbert,
a spokesman or spokesperson for the attorney general, who also
serves as the Kansas GOP chair, and shared with her excerpts
of the chat following H or involving Hendrickx. In response,
Herbert said that we are aware of the issues raised in your article
and that Hendrickx is no longer employed in Kobach's office.
>> Yeah, I had some back and forth with the VC in Michigan.
Current chair is a deer in the headlights. We have a call Wednesday.
Many agree. He did say, "My delegates I bring will vote for the
most right-wing person." Right. I love him, says uh Mr. Gient.
This is Mr. Genta again for you. Great.
>> This is rough, man. This is some rough stuff. Okay.
>> Some very rough stuff.
Uh okay. In another exchange, Dwire and the Dwire the Kansas
City chair or the Kansas's chair, the Kansas chair,
this is throwing me off,
informs Genta that one of Michigan's young Republicans promised
him the group will vote for the most right-wing person to lead
the national organization. Great. I love Genta responded. Dwire
reacted with a smiley face.
>> You minority group spared. Genta, who serves as chief
of staff to New York State Assemblyman, Assembly Member Mike
Riley, ultimately fell six points short of winning the chairship
to lead the Young Republican National Federation earlier this
year. Despite earning endorsements from Stefonic and longtime
Trump adviser Roger Stone, Riley did not respond to requests
for comment.
This is the assembly member that he is uh chief of staff for.
Earlier this year, Stefonic accepted an award from the New York
State Young Republicans. She lauded Gentto for his tremendous
leadership in August and had her campaign and the political pack
she leads donate to that state organization. Alex Degrass, a
senior adviser for Stfanic for Stefonic said the congresswoman
was absolutely appalled to learn about the alleged comments made
by leaders of the New York State young Republicans and other
state ys in a large national group chat. According to the description
provided by Politico, the comments were heinous, anti-semitic,
racist, and unacceptable. He continued, noting Stefonic has never
employed anyone in the chat. If the description by Politico is
accurate, Congresswoman Stefonic calls for any NY young Republicans
responsible for these horrific comments in this chat to step
down immediately. Zone also condemned the comments in a statement.
I of course have never seen this alleged chat room thread. He
said, "If it is authentic, I would of course denounce any such
comments in the strongest possible terms. This would surprise
me as it is inconsistent with Peter uh the Peter that I know
although I only know him in his capacity as the head of the New
York Young Republicans where I thought he did a good job. >> Okay.
Well, Roger Stone's like, "Well, I think this is fake." But even
if it weren't fake, it would be really weird cuz that's not the
Peter I know. But also, I don't know him that well. I only know
him in this one capacity where I did know him well enough to
say that he did a great job. Okay.
Roger Stone's going in circles.
Very interesting. Few minority groups are spared from the young
Republican group, young Republican groups chat. Their rhetoric,
normalized at most points as dark humor, mirrors some popular
conservative political commentators, podcasters, and comedians
amid a national erosion of what's considered acceptable discourse.
Genters Genta's line on a darker skinned pilot, for example,
echoes one used by slain conservative activist Charlie Kirk last
year when he said, "If I see a black pilot, I'm going to be like,
"Oh boy, I hope he's qualified." Kirk was discussing how diversity
hiring invites unh wholesome thinking.
Walker also uses the moniker eye patch McCain, originally coined
by conservative commentator Tucker Carlson in an apparent reference
to GOP rep. Dan Krenshaw, Krenshaw lost his eye while serving
as a Navy Seal in Afghanistan. Walker also makes the remark,
"I prefer my war heroes not captured." A repeat of a similar
2015 line from Donald Trump.
Art Gypson, a professor of the at the University of Dayton who
specializes in white racial extremism, surmised the young Republicans
in the chat were influenced by Trump's language, which he said
is often hyperbolic and emotionally charged. Trump from persistent
use of hostile, often inflammatory language that normalizes aggressive
discourse in conservative circles can be incredibly influential
on young operatives who are still trying to figure out what it
is or what is that political discourse. Gypson
uh, I think this guy's like out of the loop.
Like this is probably for a lot of people exactly why they think
Fuentes is dangerous, right? Like it's obvious when somebody's
saying I love in a group chat, right? When they're saying that,
they're referring to a very specific thing that happened.
Probably not Kanye West even, right? They're referring to like
a whole
So I I don't know. It's weird to say that like this is obviously
Trump. I feel like this is obviously like one person who talks
this way and who's pushing things in that direction, right? Is
Fentes. Like these guys all even though a bunch of these guys
look way older than Fuentes, they're almost certainly Fentes
fans, right?
Like they're pushing the exact same line of rhetoric that Fuentes
does. Like, hey, we have to move things rightwing. Like you have
to at any at any cost move things further right.
Fentes is because of Trump though. Yeah, sure. But it's not they're
not the same thing. He doesn't coordinate with Trump in any way.
You could say Fuentes is because of Trump, but he pushes in a
totally different direction than the one Trump Yeah. totally
different direction than the one Trump's supposed to uh pushing
it. And I think if I had to guess, I'm guessing Fuentes is about
to jump off of the Trump train again if he hasn't already, right?
Like Fuentes is not a fan of Trump right now. He might leave
it alone because he thinks Trump is like upsetting people or
too popular to go after, but he's like clearly not on the same
page as Trump in a lot of ways right now. My opinion at least.
Okay.
So Gypson, this is the professor from Dayton, specializes in
white racial extremism. Gypson reviewed multiple excerpts of
the Young Republicans chat provided by Politico. One was a late
July message where Mossman, the chair of the Arizona Young Republicans,
mused about how the group could win support for their preferred
candidate by linking an opponent to white supremacist groups.
But Mossman then realized that plan could backfire. Kansas's
young Republicans could end up becoming attracted to that opponent.
Can we get them to start releasing edits with her like a pro-Nazi
and fascism propaganda? He asked the group. Oh my god, I love
this plan. Rachel Hope, the Arizona Young Republicans events
chair responded. The only problem is we will lose the Kansas
delegation. Mosman said hope that Hope and the two Kansas Young
Republicans in the chat reacted with a laughing face to the message.
Guys, can we just paint them as Yeah, but then they're going
to win. Oh, true, true, true, true.
That's fair. That's fair. That's probably slightly tongue-in-cheek,
but also like funny because it's
kind of accurate. I guarantee you a lot of these people like
um what? Return to tradition memes and right any Hyperoreia memes.
They'd be really into it. You know, you know, the only problem
is we will lose. Oh, we did this one already. Gypson said young
Republicans conversations reminded him of online discussions
between members of in white supremacist groups. You say it once
or twice, it's a joke. But you say it 251 times, it's no longer
a joke. Gypson said, "The more we repeat certain ideas, the more
real they become to us." Weeks later, someone in the chat say
uh staying in a hotel asks its members to guess what room we're
in. 1488, Dwire responds. White supremacists use the number 1488
because 14 is the number of words in the white supremacist slogan.
We must secure the existence of our people and a future for white
children. H is the eighth letter in the alphabet and 88 is often
used as a shorthand for
1488.
In another conversation in February, Juna talks approvingly about
the Orange County Teenage Republican Organization in New York
which appears to be part of a network of national teenage Republicans
and how he was pleased with its young members ideological bent.
They support slavery and all that mega based. He said, "The term
based in internet culture is used to express approval with an
idea, often one that's bold or controversial."
Bro, I don't understand. This just feels like if you're trying
to paint yourself as racist and you support slavery, that almost
doesn't make sense to me in the current like world order at all.
Right? You have to understand that you'd be advocating for like
the whitest people in Appalachia to be slaves, too. Right? Like
if you're just going to go by any metric like income, uh, test
scores, anything like this, like it just doesn't it I don't know.
It just doesn't make sense to me.
Like slavery is just like overtly disgusting. It should be like
it should be disgusting to your sensibilities as like a human
being. Not in terms of race or anything. It should just be disgusting.
And then if you're just trying to say, "Oh, well, we're racist
and we just want to like put enslave black people or something."
It's like, okay, but why why would they do that? Like black people
have higher places in in culture and uh and finance than you
do right now, right? Like you're a loser. Why would you be able
to enslave another race at this point ever? They would want to
go by race again. Yeah, but they're losers. That's the thing
is like they don't have the the thing that allowed them to enslave
people before was this total this total like subjugation, the
total um difference in technology level and stuff. It's like
black people literally provide more to the country than you do.
Why why the [__] would you be able to to put them
in chains? Why the [__] would you do this? The data
is fake though. Obviously, it's DEI data. I'm just It like doesn't
make sense, right? It might have like you might have been able
to
>> I don't know, man. >> It's so backward and like
it's just so backward. It's just gross to me. Like I don't know.
>> I'll be honest. I don't think about like slavery a lot.
It just seems really disgusting to me that that you would think
that this is cool um to like unironically argue for slavery.
Even I could defend joking about stuff, right? like ironically
joking about how like oh slavery should come back like uh instead
of dead's prison we should have like indentured servitude again
or something like this right
like I could almost understand a joke but like this is just
I don't know it makes me feel uncomfortable it makes me feel
like people can't handle memes at all do you not think they're
are actual racists I do yeah obviously I do I just don't get
the impression that it's ironic here right like with some of
the other stuff
I don't know I just don't get the impression It's ironic. In
a statement, Orange County GOP Chair Courtney Canfield Green
said that the party was disappointed to learn its teen group
was mentioned in the chat. Our teen volunteers have no affiliation
with the New York State Young Republicans or the Young Republican
National
whatever the f is there. [__] I lost it. She said
uh she said this behavior is no home within the Republican party
in Orange County. Ed Cox, the chair of New York State G the New
York State GOP, also condemned the remarks made in the chat.
I was shocked and disgusted to learn about the reports of comments
made by a small group of young Republicans. He said, "Just as
we call it vile, racist, and anti-semitic rhetoric on the far
left, we must not tolerate it within our own ranks." Vicious
words for enemies. Members of the Telegram chat
speak about their personal lives, too. Extensive discussions
about their everyday lives include one exchange about how devoutly
Catholic some chat members are and how often they attend church.
Many of the slurs, epithets, and violent language used in the
chat often appear to be intended as jokes. Oman was derided by
chat me me members of the chat as a and
I don't know why I felt comfortable reading those ones stay in
the closet epsur walker of New York all suggested in July though
he is the group's main target for the same epithet group use
slurs against Asians too my people built the train tracks with
the Chinese Walker says at one point referring to his Italian
ancestors let his people go Molina responds keep the armor defects
though in another instance Mosman tells the group chat that Spanish
came to America and had the Spanish came to America and had sex
with every single woman is gay. Dwire writes it was
replies epic. Walker says,
"Did you Joe, did you look it up yet?" "Just did. Probably shouldn't
have work have on my work computer." The Spanish came to America
and had sex with every single woman. Was gay. It was epic.
There's more explicit malice in some phrases, too, especially
when they turn their eye on opponents outside the chat, such
as the leader of the rival grow young Republican slate, Hayden.
uh Hayden Padet who defeated Genta and was reelected chairman
of the Young Republican National Federation this
>> Was it with Cath? Is it Catholics? Are these people
Catholic?
>> I don't even know how you tell if they were Catholic
at this point to be honest with you.
>> Oh, what are we? We're four subs, guys. Four subs from
another two hours. Get those four subs in, guys. Get these two
hours on the stream. Okay.
I'm not gonna I'm gonna keep reading the article. So you mean
Hayden Essler wrote the resolution himself. Genta asked the group
about the young national young Republicans chair in late May.
Hayden Mossman declared the following month. See that's that's
an obvious joke. Adolf Pette is in the
bunker as we speak. Walker said in July. Pette responded to the
chat's language in a statement. The Young Republican National
Federation condemns all forms of racism, anti-semitism, and hate.
Pette said, "I want to be clear that such behavior is entirely
inconsistent with our values and has no place within our organization
or the broader conservative movement."
>> Samuel Douglas private hop. Thank you for the five gifted.
Let's go. That's two more hours. Let's Let's go. Two hours. Three.
Easy.
>> Gentto also Samuel Douglas. Dude, they just litter the
pictures in. It's so up. the person who did this, if they're
just like a political operative that this is actually one of
the most effective pieces of propaganda I've ever seen.
>> this is an incredibly effective piece of propaganda.
Like you go through the chats, you go through the denouncing,
and then you show the pictures of them, which makes even the
people who would like go like, "Oh, that's a joke. That's totally
cool." >> want to disavow. Dude, it's like incredibly effective
this whole article. I kind of can't see it as something else.
Genta had also had exploitative laden criticism for the young
Republicans in states that were supporting or leaning toward
Padet's faction. Minnesota he messaged continuing Arkansas inbred
cow Nebraska revolt in our favor block their bind and have a
majority of their delegates Maryland fat stinky
something Rhode Island traitorous
who I will eradicate from the face of this planet again. Uh that's
this guy. Okay, that's this guy. Those those are the thoughts
going on in this guy's head. all the time.
Like like you read it and then you're like, "Oh, that's like
this guy. That's like this guy talking." I was like, "Bro, are
you serious?" Okay.
Juna also said he planned to make one of the competing young
Republicans unal alive himself on the convention floor. In another
instance, Douglas, the Vermont state senator, describes to the
group members how one of Pett's
colleagues may have made a procedural error related to the number
of Maryland delegates permitted at the national convention. I
was about to say you're giving nationals to
uh nationals to blank much credit to
some curse. Much credit and expecting the to be honest. Brianna
Douglas, Sam's wife and Vermont Young Republicans National Committee
member replied to her husband's message. Brianna Douglas did
not respond to repeated requests for comments.
Dude, dude,
This guy's wife's in here dropping the racism as well. She's
like outdoing him. This is what you get for trusting the Okay,
you trust a Jew to be honest. Yeah, you get what you deserve.
>> If we ever read a leak of this chat while reporting
this article article article, Politico was examining a separate
allegation that Genta and the Young Republicans mismanaged the
New York organization's finances and hadn't paid at least one
venue for a swanky holiday party it hosted last year. Politico's
report detailed how the organization was missing required financial
disclosure forms and how their subsequent efforts to file the
forms revealed the organization was in more than $28,000 of debt
as of Tuesday. Updated records show the organization is more
than $38,000 in debt. Donations to New York State Young Republicans
political account must be reported to the state board of elections.
Expenditures must be reported, too. At the time, Genta told Politico
the allegations were nothing more than a sad and pathetic attempt
at a political hit job. But in the restore yr war room chat,
he and Walker speak flippantly about mishandling the club's finances.
New York State Young Republicans account be like, $500 balding
cream, $1,000 ompic. Walker said in one message, New York State
New York State Young Republicans will be declaring bankruptcy
after I after this. I just know it, he said in another. There's
no way.
>> Bro, what?
Who's got the bad hairline here?
>> Is it this guy? Hold on. Who are these two? It's uh
>> this is Walker.
>> Who is Walker again? There's no way. Walker's the guy.
Walker's the groper, right? No, Walker's this guy. That's This
is Walker.
>> Okay. Jesus. I drained $10,000 tonight to pay for my
next vacation to Italy. Ja appeared to joke about the organization's
bank account. I spent it on massage, she says of another check
that was deposited in the account. Great. Can't wait to get sued.
Buy our venue, Walker replies. Members of the chat occasionally
appeared to be aware of its toxicity and even made remarks that
considered the possibility someone outside their tightnit group
could view it. Walker seemed to consider that possibility the
most. In one instance, he joked about bombing the young na young
Republican National Federation's convention in Nashville, then
remarked, "Just kidding for a signed FBI tracker." In another,
he considered the totality of the thousands of messages he and
his peers had written and what would happen if the public saw
them come to light. "If we ever had a leak of this chat, we would
be cooked for real. For real, he
>> that's the whole article. Okay, >> we would be
cooked. For real. For real. For real.
>> Just straight up admitting to embezzling. Well, one
of them seemed like it could possibly be serious.
Why would another Republican leak it? Because obviously, one,
Harmony,
you could easily just do this. You could easily just save this
stuff and wait to use it later. But two, if somebody was losing
something, if they felt like their political political career
was over and they wanted to extract money or favors from these
people, you could leak it then, right? Like let's say one of
these people becomes disgraced through another means, then what
incentive do they have to keep this group chat private, especially
if you did something to them or if they perceive you did something
to them? >> Like this is just creating leverage against
you yourself or yourself if you participate this way
or if they suddenly get trolls remorse if they suddenly become
like Idubbbz. Yeah, that could be another example.
Yep, yep, yep, yep. I saw a couple different posts about this.
I don't think I'm going to go through all the responses, but
I saw one from this guy. Until every Democrat denounces Jay Jones's
text fantasizing about murdering Republicans and their children,
I won't give a about edgy jokes by young Republicans in group
chats. Oh, it's the it's the destiny response. Guys, your people
have to denounce. Okay, your people have to denounce this or
I won't. This is fine by me as long as you guys don't denounce.
I'm just going to put all my morality on the people I claim are
morally incapable of making good decisions. This is why Discords
are dumb and will be used against you. Probably anyway. Leftists
are plotting assassinations in group chats. They're celebrating
in public, too. What about the Young Republicans racist Telegram
group? Wait, you guys are in group chats? I don't even understand
the meme here. This is probably a bot account. Mullet and memes.
Is this a botted account?
This just could be a botted account. Cool. Okay. Do any of the
dudes have Twitter accounts? I don't know.
>> right? Almost certainly.
>> Who's the Who's the big guy? Genta.
>> What was Genta's first name here? Peter Genta. See if
we can find a Twitter
>> Highlights from Peter Genta. Oh, he's he's privated.
We're privated. And this is him. We can see him. We see you.
We see you, buddy. Okay. Well, well, I guess we're uh we're probably
about done with this one. Is Gavin Wax the guy who leaked it?
Yes, Gavin Wax is the guy who leaked it. Well, Gavin Wax is the
guy who pressured one of the people who were participating to
leak it,
right?
He has a Twitter. Gavin Wax Twitter. Let's take a look. Gavin
Wax. Gavin
>> Uh, would this be him?
New York. New York YRC. New York Young
Club. Okay. Gavin Wax.
Okay. That guy looks a little more normal. All right.
Any posts about this?
>> Uh, doesn't look like he's posting anything here. Doesn't
look like he's posting anything about this.
>> Nothing. No comments, man. No comments at all. Wonder
what his career change is going to look like. I don't know if
any of them I don't know if any of them are going to have an
actual change of any kind. Okay, doesn't seem likely. Let's see
here. Okay, we're going to move forward on to the next thing.
Okay, I've got I've got a lot of politics stuff left over as
well.
Let me take a quick look at this. What is this? Son's e-collar
controversy breakdown. You need to see
this breakdown. You need to see. Wait, why was it?
Okay. Well, it's not going to pop up the video. I'll just watch
Chud watch it for a quick second.
>> What is this? Because I've seen a lot of I've seen a
lot of professional trainers just say, "Yeah, obviously we um
we using this shit." >> Let's go.
>> Oh, it's >> Let's get some super chats in, guys.
Come on. We're leeching. >> Y'all are just hearing us live.
Sorry, we just did a whole minute and it didn't catch till right
now. So, this is what we're doing today. We're discussing the
collargate, the issue with Hassan [__] a gentleman
that I don't know at all. Never met him. I don't know anything
about him. First time I heard of his name was uh maybe in the
last 24 to 48 >> What is this music? I don't know. I just
I literally let some play. I start from like this song, right?
I always start from this river of darkness song with the saxophones
and then it just picks whatever it's going to pick. Man, this
is the one I pick. I just don't It's so loud. I do have it a
little loud. Okay.
It's not so bad when it's just my voice that's talking >> because
of the so-called e-collar shot caller scandal that's I guess
kind of spreading like wildfire across the internet. And what
we're talking about is a
while on a live stream
>> purportedly used is that even the right
>> Hold on a second. Hold on a second. Hold on a second.
>> Hold on. Hold on.
This one's not so bad. I feel like we
>> This is pretty good. Okay,
>> he does fit in. He fits in very well. I feel like I
feel like Top Bronson did this. You actually slimmed him down
a lot. He's like slimmed down from the actual picture.
This is not actually making him as wide as he is.
>> great stuff, Top. Thank you so much, Todd Bronson. We
We really treasure you here. Okay. >> Purportedly. And
>> Assan reacted to Mo's critical making event. I still
I saw a clip at the front. If you got the time stamp, stick my
Discord and I'll throw it out >> at the source as we do
these lives. Supposedly used a shock collar on his dog in the
background. Uh something happens. His dog gives out a vocal yelp.
Uh, and what the controversy is, and please weigh in on this,
Spider again. Spider is my production manager. He's miked up.
He's the one that brought it to my attention. And >> we
have this go for >> some of the controversies that surround
>> Oh, this Yeah, we got the the time stamp at the beginning.
Um,
I don't know. I kind of was committed to this. I actually don't
super care to be honest with you. Is this okay, but it's like
we No, we don't care. We don't care. I would much rather just
get to the Fentto's Gavin McKinnus debate tonight.
>> All right,
>> as a quick pallet cleanser, we're gonna do some politics.
All right, quick pallet cleanser. >> I head over to this
George Stephanopoulos JD Vance interview that I just wanted to
highlight because it was stupid. I I watched it um we watched
it on the way home yesterday. I think we listened to it or two
days ago.
Vice President JD Van sat down for an interview with ABC anchor
George Stephanopoulos on Sun. >> Oh, I this up. Hold on.
>> I grabbed the rising video and not the actual interview.
Give me a second.
>> We're joined now by Vice President JD Vance. Mr. Vice,
thank you for joining us this morning. Let's start with the Middle
East. The Wall Street Journal is reporting that has confirmed
they are holding 20 living hostages and that those hostages are
going to be released in the next 24 hours. as early as today
perhaps two nights ago. >> Have 20 living hostages been
confirmed? When do you expect to see them? >> Well, they've
been confirmed, George. Of course, you don't know until you see
these people alive, but thank God we expect to see them alive
here in the next 24 hours, probably early tomorrow morning, US
time, which will be later in the day, of course, in Israel. But
but look, George, we have to remember this is a remarkable achievement
from an administration that really chose a non-conventional path
to diplomacy. And I think that's the major takeaway. The president
of the United States instructed Mark Marco Rubio, Jared Kushner,
Steve Wickoff said, "Get a deal done. Talk to the Gulf Arab states.
Uh talk You guys notice how like all the praise for Trump is
very much like the praise that used to come down for Steve Jobs.
It's like only Trump could have told his guys to get it done.
Only Trump could have been like, "Hey guys, I think you should
think about getting it done." I know you haven't thought about
getting it done. I know you're not thinking about like making
progress or getting something tangible, but like yeah, have you
guys just do it, okay? Just do the >> to Israel, find where
there's common ground here and actually let's go and find a way
to get it done. Because of that, we are on the cusp of true peace
in the Middle East. Really, for the first time in my lifetime.
Certainly, these 20 hostages are going to come home to their
families. George, I think this is a great moment for our country.
Our country should be proud of our diplomats who made this happen.
Uh it's really a great moment for the world, too, which is why
the president is going to go over there and celebrate with these
hostages. But it's it's a great thing and I'm very excited about
it. >> 200 US troops are being sent to Israel to monitor
the agreement. What exactly will they be doing? Will they actually
go into Gaza? And are you concerned they could get caught in
some crossfire, >> George? So, that story is actually misreported.
We already have troops at central command. We've had them for
decades in this country. They are going to monitor the terms
of the ceasefire. And that's everything from ensuring that the
Israeli troops are at the agreed upon line, ensuring that is
not attacking innocent Israelis, doing everything that they can
to ensure the peace that we've created. >> Oh, also
horrible, horrible freeze frame right here. But also, I forgot
to say I think wasn't weren't there reports this morning that
the ceasefire was violated.
I thought there were reports that the ceasefire was literally
violated.
Hold on. I'm pulling up this uh ring.
>> Are you going to say please and thank you to me?
>> Oh, this applies to that Tactical Templar video from
earlier today, right?
Why Why haven't you said thank you to Donald Trump for ending
the war? Why haven't you said thank you? Why won't you do it?
Yeah, that's uh that's going back to the video that that Tactical
Templar video yesterday was so disgusting.
What a gross person.
>> Ceasefires are usually violated. Wouldn't worry about
it yet. Okay. Well,
>> actually sustains and endures. But the idea that we're
going to have troops on the ground in Gaza in Israel, that that
is not our intention. That is not our plan. There was a bit of
a misreporting there, but we are going to monitor this piece
to ensure uh that it that it endures. The the other piece of
good news that's been underreported, I think, George, is that
Indonesia and a number of other majority Muslim states, they've
actually offered to send ground troops to Gaza to to ensure the
necessary peacekeeping takes place. That's not something the
United States is going to be expected to do. That's something
the Muslim world is going to step up and do. And that again is
because of the Trump administration's diplomacy. >> The
president has also pushed for National Guard deployments in several
American cities. As you know, that's been questioned by several
federal judges, including Trump appointees. Also, the Republican
governor of Oklahoma, chairman of the National Governance Association,
Kevin St. Here's what Governor Stit said. We believe in the federalist
system that state that states rights. Oklahomaans would lose
their mind if Pritzkar and Illinois send troops down to Oklahoma
during the Biden administration. How do you respond to Governor
Ste? >> So, how do you respond to this Republican who's
clearly stating how your country's supposed to function, right?
You're a federation of states. You're you have a federalist system
that you're supposed to respect the rights of the other states.
Each state is supposed to respect the rights of the other states.
How do you feel about that? And then the national government,
the federal government is supposed to respect the rights of each
state. How do you feel about that, JD?
>> Well, I'd say the governor state, you have to look at
what's happening on the ground in Chicago. And the reason why
Illinois is a different case from Chicago is because Chicago
has been given over to lawlessness and gangs for too long. George,
if you look at the murder rates in Chicago, the violent crime
rates, you have you have women who have young families. They're
terrified their their kids are going to get killed in a drive-by
shooting. We have accepted this for far too long in the United
States of America in some of our biggest cities and
>> uh Chicago has crime. Did you guys know that Chicago
has crime? Chicago's got
>> Oh wow. >> Chicago unfortunately is the worst.
It's a beautiful city. It's got great people. We know the gross
majority of the violent crime in that city is committed by a
very tiny fraction of the population. Why shouldn't federal troops
empower the people in Chicago to live safe lives when the governor
and local the local mayor just simply refuse to do their job?
>> But why couldn't you just work with the local government
and say, "Hey, we're willing to give you all of the resources
you need to crack down on crime in that city."
Right? It's just that it's like this is like people not understanding.
This is basically like Yeah. Like JD Vance somebody. We're all
like, "Dude, what the are you doing? That's so disgusting that
you would violate that person's that person's like uh autonomy,
their their rights like that. It's it's gross." And he's like,
"I I just had people have all the time." Like, bro, no, no, no.
You're you're actually missing the entire point here that it's
about whether or not they're consenting to you entering their
state.
Like, that's the whole purpose of this is you should have that
you have a legal system that's set up. You have states rights.
Your your government is set up this way so that you are supposed
to respect what the state wants. You are just you're and how
do you think this would work? Like if the na if the national
government the actual um like if DC doesn't respect states rights,
isn't that a huge issue for Republicans? Hasn't that been how
Republicans have acted for years and years and years that like
everything is states right uh state states rights issue
and you're just totally changing up how you guys handle this
now? you're like, "Oh, yeah, the it's totally fine that we're
going to deploy the army in these places or to deploy the National
Guard in these places." >> But as you know, a federal judge,
a US district judge has blocked the effort to deploy troops in
Chicago. And it was Judge Perry and she actually said that a
lot of these claims that were made, especially in the court filings,
lack >> Well, George, we're obviously going to litigate
this as much as we can. We think that we have the authority to
provide proper safety to our citizens all over the United States,
but particularly in Chicago. But I think for any federal judge
or anybody else to look at this situation and say, "Is it tolerable?"
And I think the obvious answer, George, is no. The president
looks at the situation. He sees the fact that you have multiple
people dying of murders every weekend in the city of Chicago.
And he says this is intolerable. And it's not just the people
who live in Chicago. It's the law enforcement in Chicago, federal,
state, and local, who are trying to keep us safe. George, you've
seen ICE agents being teed off on in suburban Chicago in >> Oh,
this is also disgusting that it's like obviously ICE is far worse
in Chicago in terms of the [__] they're doing.
But not just that, he's about to reference the Dallas stuff,
too. >> All over the state of Illinois and other places,
too. You see a thousand% increase in violence against our ICE
agents. They're being assaulted. They're being beaten. They're
being shot at. I think all Americans, Democratic or Republican,
we look at this scenario, we say, "This is not acceptable. We
want people to be safe. We want our law enforcement officials
to be empowered to keep us safe. We can do this." And that's
exactly what the Trump administration has committed to doing.
>> Governor Pritzkar is our next guest. President Trump
has said that he should be in jail. Do you think Governor Pritzkar
has committed a crime?
Okay, now watch. So this is the thing that disgusts me most is
JD Vance is incapable of answering this question and I think
people have to like make him answer these questions or or you
have to point out that he is like lying. You just have to like
start laughing at him laughing at how badly he is dodging the
question, right? So what he's going to do here is he's he's going
to be asked does JB Pritskar deserve to go to prison? You're
arguing JB Pritzkar deserves to go to prison or sorry, Trump
is arguing that. Do you think there's any merit to it and he
will not actually engage with that question whatsoever?
>> Well, I think Governor Pritsker has certainly failed
to keep the people of Illinois safe. And it's interesting to
me, you know, Governor Pritsker will talk a lot, I'm sure, about
how bad Donald Trump is, about how bad I am, and about how bad
the administration is. He is the >> res my
uh Bluetooth here. Just give me a sec. I had to reset the headphones.
Couldn't even hear it.
Could have also cut out there when they reconnected, but I think
we should be back now. My headphones were cut out super bad.
>> The governor of a state that me >> how bad I am
and about how bad the administration is. He is the governor of
a state that where it's big. >> You know, Governor Pritsker
will talk a lot, I'm sure, about how bad Donald Trump is, about
how bad I am, and about how bad the administration is. He is
the governor of a state that where its biggest city has murder
rates that that rival the most violent places in the third world.
George, why is he so mad at Donald Trump for trying to keep Chicagoans
safe? He should be mad at the criminals that he has failed to
keep at bay. We're trying to help him. >> Why is he so
mad at Trump for breaking the law? Why Why is he so mad at Trump
for breaking the law, guys? >> And we're trying to help
the resident. >> You should be be mad about other people
breaking the law that caused Trump to break the law. Okay. >> Of
his biggest city. I wish that he would let us because he certainly
isn't doing the job himself. >> I asked if you agree with
President Trump that Governor Pritzkar has committed a crime.
>> Well, I think that Governor Pritsker has allowed a lot
of people to be killed in the city of Chicago.
>> Dude, it's just like the Tom Hman thing. Did you guys
see his answers on Tom Hman? I think he does the same thing in
this interview with the Tom Hman thing.
No, I asked like, do you think he's committed a crime? Well,
I think he's like, "Let people die and uh whatever the consequences
for that should be, you know, he should get those consequences."
>> And elsewhere, George, I think that it's disgraceful.
And I think >> uh he's done it in multiple interviews.
>> He absolutely should suffer some consequences for the
fact that there are thousands of innocent Chicagoans who are
dead because he failed to do his job. >> It's a it's really
a yes or no question. Do you believe he's committed a crime?
>> George, you're gonna keep on asking this question. And
I'm going to keep on telling you that Governor Prrisker has failed
to do his job. He should >> So, President Trump is wrong
is what you're saying cuz you won't go as far as to say this
is you need to you need to be very precise with these people,
right? So, yes, they're all Marco Rubio. Every single Republican
is Marco Rubio from 2016. That's this software patch they have
because they can't answer for any of the things they're actually
doing. And so, they will just lie or pretend the they will have
like strokes on on the live. Okay, that's what Steven Miller
did when he just stopped talking. He just froze like a bot. That's
what he did, too. They're always going to stop and freeze like
bots now. And you just have to mock them and make fun of them
for it. They have to be mocked, even by the mainstream media.
They have to be mocked. It's like a hard requirement, a harsh
requirement. Okay. When uh Todd Bronson informs me that we've
done an extra fat pass on this guy. I for some reason this popped
up as like a way lower resolution. Hold on. Hold on. There we
go. We got a We got a faster pass uh a fatter pass over this
guy. Okay, not faster. Although also faster. And then we have
one more with uh him edited in there from Critical Rad. Let's
go.
Let's go. Good stuff. We had to make him bigger. Okay. He wasn't
big enough. He had to be made bigger.
>> All right. Back to JD. >> Suffer some consequences.
Whether he's violated a crime ultimately, I would leave to the
courts, but I certainly think that he has violated his fundamental
oath of office. That seems pretty criminal to me. I'd leave it
to a judge and jury to decide whether he's actually violated
the crime. >> Could you tell us why Donald Trump thinks
he's viol why he's violated a crime? Whatever the that means,
why he's broken the law. Could you tell us why Donald Trump's
doing this? Because I see you basically saying Donald Trump's
wrong. You are telling me Donald Trump's wrong. Could you tell
me why you think Donald Trump's wrong? Uh, let me also ask you
as we saw the indictment this week of Leticia James on questions
of of mortgage fraud, also Lisa Cook, >> but they all just
move on. Yeah, they all just move on and it's like like I'm Well,
no, he gets heated with him eventually, but they all just move
on all the time. And it's like, dude, start pointing out that
these people can't answer questions, that they're like broken
robots. They're all Marco Rubio from 2016. It's I see the Marco
Rubio moment multiple times a week now where somebody literally
can't answer a question. book is has been accused by the Trump
administration of committing mortgage fraud as well. Uh the journalism
outlet ProPublica has actually published a story and I want to
show it up on the screen right now uh that says that several
members of the Trump administration have faced similar questions.
Labor Secretary Lorie Chavez Durmer entered into two primary
res
>> Apparently um the idea is you I think if you identify
something as your primary residence, you get like a what a cheaper
mortgage. you get like a lower interest mortgage rate, right,
for your first house. And there's some question about whether
or not these people refer to multiple homes as their primary
residence or whether you can do that between states like this,
right? And so apparently a whole bunch of people in the Trump
administration have done the same thing that Leticia James just
got indicted for. >> In quick succession, Transportation
Secretary Shawn Duffy has primary residence mortgages in New
Jersey and Washington DC. Lee Zeldon, the Environmental Protection
Agency administrator ad administrator has one primary residence
mortgage in Long Island and another in Washington DC. How do
you respond to critics who say that the Trump administration
is engaging in a double standard here? >> Well, I'd say
two things, George. First of all, ProPublica is basically a left-wing
blog. I'm not shocked that you found a left-wing blog that can
attack members of the Trump administration. But second, and this
is the most important, is what does the law say? Leticia James
was indicted in a left-leaning part of our country, a part that
voted very heavily against Donald J. Trump for the crime of mortgage
fraud. When I read the indictment, when I read the facts in the
case, I see a person who committed mortgage fraud. Now, of course,
the jury is going to decide. >> So, the thing here is you
got to go with the Comey thing and then I need to know what the
facts of the Comey case are, right? With the Comey case, I see
a suspicious, almost like
almost malicious
lack of factual representation of the charges. You don't even
say what he lied about in the indictment. How is there an indictment
produced? You haven't even decided what he lied about yet. You've
indicted him for lying and you don't specify what the lie is.
>> Whether she ultimately committed a crime, uh, we don't
try her. The administration doesn't try her. a judge tries the
case and a jury decides whether she's ultimately guilty. That
is what is going to determine whether she goes to prison. I think
we let the facts drive this. And George, that's what we've tried
to do in the administration's department. >> So basically,
I don't know, Robo Vance like like bot Vance MPC Vance just up
because what George did was he said, "Here's a bunch of Republicans
who have done the same thing Leticia James did,
And I assume you would want them to also face charges for mortgage
fraud, right? So if you just say it's the facts, then these people
obviously the facts apply in the exact same way. Obviously you
you think these people should be indicted for mortgage fraud,
right? Justice, we've asked ourselves, has a person violated
the law? And if that person has violated the law, then we decide
to prosecute them. That's what the Department of Justice should
do. It didn't do that under Joe Biden's administration. It does
under Donald Trump's. On the facts, do you dispute the facts
that ProPublica reported? >> Do I dispute a far-left blog
that I haven't read that you brought up in this interview? I
have no idea, George. I have no idea what they actually said,
but I certainly >> It's just so transparent, right? It's
so transparent every time. Uh I don't know what you're talking
about there. I haven't read that. And uh yeah, do I dispute the
things that you just reported to me? Uh well, I I kind of think,
you know, that's a left-wing rag and so I don't trust anything
they say. Okay, dude. >> Question the source. I question
their credibility. And most importantly, I'm not worried about
what they said about members of our administration. I asked the
question, what does the law say? And if the law says that you
engage in mortgage fraud and a local prosecutor, a local grand
>> uh Moody Morgan, uh the reason we didn't point it out
is because it's a stupid argument for one thing. I could have
pointed out, but it's a grand jury that indicted, right? So,
they're saying a a jury of their peers indicted them. a grand
jury assigned or uh what you call it convened other peers and
and said that they were, you know, they should be indicted on
this charge. Now, I don't know. I I'm guessing that jury gets
instructions on things, right? I would love to see the jury instructions
that they got to like I'm sure they're instructed on how they
should interpret the facts. So, it'd be very interesting to see
how that was all laid out. >> Jury and a and finally a
jury convicts you of that crime, then that is how the justice
system is meant to work in the United States of America.
The White House borders our Tom Hman was recorded on an FBI surveillance.
>> Grand juries only hear the pro. Yeah, exactly. I want
whatever they said. I want that all laid out. Certainly for Comey
cuz I don't think Comey is guilty at all. I think they know Comey
is not guilty and I think they totally trumped up charges to
put him through a trial and Comey's kind of like happy about
it because he gets to go and prove that they're basically lying
completely. >> Tape in September 2024 accepting $50,000
in cash. >> Did he keep that money or give it back?
George, you've covered the story ad nauseium. Tom H. Home. did
not take a bribe. It's a ridiculous smear. And the reason you
guys are going after Tom Hman so aggressively is because he's
doing the job of enforcing the law. I I think it's really preposterous.
I know Tom. I think that he's a good man. He gets death threats.
He gets attacked. He gets constantly
threatened by people because he has the audacity to want to enforce
the country's immigration laws. I
>> uh that's not an answer to the question. You just once
again totally slid past the question, right? It was pretty easy.
Did he keep the money or did he give it back? You didn't answer
anything yet. You haven't done.
Did he keep the money given to him by officers who were doing
a sting operation? Did he keep that money or do you give it back?
Which one? >> I think that it would be a much more interesting
story about why is it that Tom H. woman who is simply enforcing
Americans immigration laws is getting constantly harassed and
threatened to the point of death threats. That's a much more
interesting question that I think journalists should focus on.
We It's not It's not an interesting question. I literally don't
care about that. I care about you hiring people and retaining
people in your government, in your administration, who have committed
major ethical violations. You knowingly retain them. You literally
clean those those violations up for them. you dismiss the case
against them. That's incredibly concerning. That's that goes
to the foundation of our trust in government. The thing you're
talking about is people being asked is people like reacting as
uh with anger towards like stories. That's totally understandable.
That's boring as not we nobody wants that guy to get death threats,
but that's not confusing. Nobody's concerned or or confused about
why that could be happening.
How about you explain why the you closed an investigation into
this guy and apparently he just took the bribe
and then did he get to keep the money? >> We can agree
to disagree on that >> Wait, you said he didn't take a
bribe, but I'm not sure you answered the question. Are you saying
that he did not accept the $50,000?
>> George, this story has been covered ad nauseium. He
did not take a bribe. Did he accept $50,000? I'm sure that in
the course of Tom Hman's life, he has been paid more than $50,000
for services. The dude that's dude can you can you imagine can
you imagine take this person seriously after this? I'm sure in
the course of his whole life he's taken $50,000 for services
at some point.
Like actually the steam is coming out of his ears.
>> Bro did not take a bribe. Did he accept $50,000? I'm
sure that in the course of Tom Hman's life he has been paid more
than $50,000 for services. The question is, did he do something
illegal? And there's abs. >> No, the question is not, did
he do something illegal? That is not what people are concerned
about. I don't care. I don't care if it was legal for Trump to
do some crypto scam and make $2 billion. I don't give a It's
about the ethics of the situation and whether or not you should,
as the president of the United States, be doing that when crypto
is a burgeoning field and you have like ultimate executive authority
over regulating it. It's insane. Like the legality of these situations,
the legality of whether or not Tom Hman can get away with accepting
that bribe based on a technicality is not important to me. Did
he accept $50,000 under the opaces of doing favors or or uh doing
out contracts to the people who were bribing him, who were giving
him the $50,000? Is are is that the quid proquo that was understood
there? Was he was he implying that? Is that how he got the
And if it's not, then would you release the tapes of this conversation
and details of the investigation so we can all confirm that?
>> Absolutely no evidence that Tom Hol
is working in the administration. I >> I'm asking you,
did he accept the $50,000 that was caught on the surveillance?
Did he accept that $50,000 or not? >> George, I don't know
what you're talking about. Did he accept $50,000 for what?
>> He was recording. Okay. So, right there.
Are you ser? You just started answering this question as if you
know what's going on and then you go, "I don't even know." Wait,
did he What are you talking about? I didn't hear about this guy.
What do you mean he took $50,000 in a grocery bag from Cabba?
Uh JD, we actually didn't tell you the details that he took it
in a grocery bag from Cava. How did you know that? Well, I just
don't know any of the story. I just guessed a a random supermarket
chain. I have no idea what's going on here.
>> It's insane. It's insane. It's insane. It's insane.
It's insane. I like I can't even like scream about it anymore.
It's just like I feel like muted. Did he accept that $50,000
or not? >> George, I don't know what you're talking about.
Did he accept $50,000 for what?
>> He was recorded on an audio tape in September 2024,
an FBI surveillance tape, accepting $50,000 in cash. Did he keep
that money? >> Accepting $50,000 for doing what, George?
I'm not even sure I understand the question. Is it illegal to
take a payment for doing services? The FBI has not prosecuted
him. I've never seen any evidence that he's engag. >> Is
it illegal to take a payment for services?
Um, well, the question is, is that is a question. Is it literally
illegal before you're nominated? Okay. No, they're actually doing
this. BB Poison. They're actually doing this. So, basically,
the FBI only came into him because they were running a drag operation
looking for people who would be willing to sell government contracts
to them. It was a part of a routine long-running operation where
they basically present themselves as people who were willing
to pay to get favorable looks at government contracts. Tom Hman
put himself in the center of that operation and accepted $50,000
in a grocery bag and is now going, "Well, technically I wasn't
a part of that administration yet, so I couldn't have sold anything
to you. I didn't have the ability to fulfill that bribe, so I
was really just accepting cash. It was like $50,000 with no strings
attached." That's the I know that's the argument they're going
with and they will not release any of the details because I know
and they know that it will be obvious that that's what they're
trying to say. And they actually ended this probe into him instead
of firing him. So basically he was not yet in the uh in the administration.
So basically they're going to argue because he had no ability
to give the to to uh like give the contracts that the bribe wasn't
a bribe. It was like I don't even know. I have no idea
over what to get government contracts for immigration work.
So it was a part of a sting operation where they're basically
presenting themselves as a contractor who would give money to
get uh government contracts in the future, right? And they knew
that Tom Hman, Trump had already announced Tom Hman was going
to be somebody they'd bring in on immigration. They knew that
that was going to be the guy who goes there, right?
You know about Uranium 1? I I don't know enough about it to care.
Six hard.
Uh, if Hillary Clinton was enough to accept just money in a bag
for a obvious quit proquo from the FBI,
I would want her head cut off, too. Okay, figuratively. But here's
the thing.
Okay, here's the thing. This Tom Hman guy got caught by the FBI
doing this. He didn't just like possibly do a quid proquo in
some way that is like nebulous and possibly ethically um suspicious.
He straight up took a a cash bribe from the >> Engaged
in criminal wrongdoing. Nobody has accused Tom of violating a
crime, even the far-left media like yourself. So, I'm actually
not sure what the precise question is. Did he accept $50,000?
Honestly, George, I I don't know the answer to that question.
What I >> Dude. Dude, dude know is that he didn't violate
a crime. >> So, you don't What would >> imagine saying
violate a crime? What I do know is that he didn't violate a >> And
then you look this smug after saying it. You like do this little
smile. >> So you don't >> you this little side eye
right here
after you say violate a crime for the eighth time in an interview
looking like a complete uneducated [__] to everybody.
Well, I don't know if he violated a crime. One, why are you commenting
at all if you don't know the details at all? Why are you commenting?
Why are you sweeping for this guy without knowing the details?
And then two, why are you lying about not knowing the details?
Because you are obviously lying. Or how do you know that Tom
Homman shouldn't be getting like people upset with him? Probably
not death threats, but how do you know people shouldn't be upset
with Tom Hman? How are you defending Tom Hman and saying it's
a story that people are upset with him if you have no idea what's
going on? >> What what was caught on the tape? You're saying
right now you don't know whether or not he kept that money. >> I
don't know what tape you're referring to, George. I saw media
reports that Tom H. Homeman accepted a bribe. There's no evidence
of that. And here's
>> George. Why? >> I just want I want this guy to
like stub his toe. Okay. But like times a
>> Fewer and fewer people watch your program and why you're
losing credibility because you're talking for now 5 minutes with
the vice president of the United States about this story regarding
Tom Holman and a story that I've read about, but I don't even
know the video that you're talking about. Meanwhile, low-income
women can't get food because the Democrats and Guys, guys, there's
a genocide going on in Palestine. Oh, wait. No, we stopped that.
Wait, there was a genocide going on in Palestine. Yes, I know.
I know. BB Poison, I know. And this is where I think it's about
to get heated here at the end. But it's like nobody nobody who
votes for these people watches this. Nobody understands that
they're voting for people who are just lying, cheating, stealing.
They're just crooks.
They just go, "Oh, well, every politician, every politician's
crooked. Every politician lies." Nope. Not like this. and Chuck
Schumer have shut down the government. Right now, we're trying
to figure out how to pay our troops because Chuck Schumer has
shut down the government. You are focused on a bogus story. You're
insinuating criminal wrongdoing against a guy who has done nothing
wrong instead of focusing on the fact that our country is struggling
because our government's shut down. Let's talk about the real
issues, George. I think the American people would benefit much
more from that than from you going down some weird left-wing
rabbit hole where the facts clearly show that Tom Hman didn't
engage in any criminal wrongdoing. >> Uh, it's not a weird
left-wing rabbit hole. I didn't insinuate anything. I asked you
whether Tom Hman accepted $50,000 as was heard on an audio tape
recorded by the FBI in September 2024, and you did not answer
the question. Thank you for your time this morning. >> I
asked you, you didn't answer the question. He should have pointed
out all the other questions he didn't answer, too, cuz Goofy.
okay. All right.
It's just It's wild that this is how this [__] goes,
man. It's just it's wild. But,
you know, we're going to have a lot more of this going on in
the background.